Batman has a coterie of super villains joker
riddler mad hatter you said you were a superhero
like batman Welcome back everyone this will be my
full dc peacemaker episode 4 video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them we're also doing a giveaway for hbo
max subscriptions all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
easter egg from the episode on the video you see
batman doesn't kill people because he's a he's
a dark creature of the night careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll
be talking about everything and i'll just start
at the beginning and work our way through scene by
scene talking about easter eggs and moments as we
go along starting with the episode title the chode
less traveled is a reference to the road less
traveled and peacemaker thinking of himself as
a chode like he says i'm a chode and not the
good kind as if there is a good kind of chode
for all you who don't know what a chode is and
you're googling that now enjoy yourselves that's
going to be fun for you but the title is also
a reference to peacemaker being on the road
to becoming a less despicable person and
also trying to atone for killing rick flagg
the actual opening scene of them driving back in
the team van back to their base after learning
the truth of project butterfly successfully
killing senator goff and peacemaker lying
about killing the butterfly capturing in a jar
so he can learn more about it they also have
judo master unconscious and in tow mirn also
finally agrees to let vigilante on the team
formally because he needs as many crazy people as
possible because what they're doing is so crazy
when they're arguing about vigilante peacemaker
makes a reference to matter eater lad from dc
comics saying his radar for knowing when teammates
are crazy is totally messed up after working with
him he said he saw him eat an entire wendy's
restaurant from the foundation up like literally
the physical restaurant itself that's his power he
can eat anything it took too long with his fries
i feel like there's a potential for an ad
campaign here like rick and morty has done
a billion wendy's ads they're all pretty funny
they could totally do the version of that with
the peacemaker series like a peacemaker wendy's
ad to pay off the joke about matter eater lad
if you're not familiar with that character it's
a super deep cut from the legion of superheroes
so by association the legion of superheroes is now
canon to the dceu the same way that batmite is now
canon to the dc eu his powers are exactly what
they sound like he can eat anything he can chew
through anything even superman that's right he
could take a bite out of superman and consume him
for sustenance they create this parallel between
peacemaker and leota's character in their problems
both pulling triggers both of them had trouble
killing people peacemaker because he's all torn
up about killing rick flag and then we see some
flashbacks about what's causing that and what
he's dealing with inside his head leota's having a
version of that but it's not quite the same thing
but there's this parallel between amanda waller
being this bad parent trying to condition her
turning her into a weapon the same way the
peacemaker's father is a terrible parent
turning him into a weapon as a child we'll see
who winds up being the more terrible character
peacemaker's father or amanda waller the
whole scene with peacemaker and vigilante
being passive-aggressive with each other is all
just part of peacemaker's arc and vigilante's arc
both sort of coming to terms with the way they've
been lying to themselves being completely out of
touch with reality it's all part of peacemaker's
arc this season turning into less of a douche and
becoming more of a normal-ish person normal-ish
not normal he's never going to be normal but a
more self-aware person and probably eventually
confronting his father over all the things that
he did to him to turn him into such a crazy person
vigilante's arc is pretty much the same situation
coming to terms with the death of his family and
what happened with his father leaving their family
the only difference with him is that he's still
able to actually pull a trigger no problem the way
they played this scene at his father's house they
make it seem like peacemaker doesn't understand
the metaphor or the reference with the upside-down
american flag being this big neo-nazi symbol
if you're a fan of the boys tv show you might
actually remember this because during season
two of the boys the stormfront nazi character
not neo-nazi because she was one of the original
members of that party during world war ii for real
and in present day her superhero costume has an
upside down american flag on it and it's one of
the signs used by neo-nazi white supremacists
so on that show it was sort of meant to give away
what was going on with her character before they
fully revealed her backstory and during episode
3 they reveal the peacemaker's father was the
dceu version of the super villain white dragon
they literally show us his super villain costume
later in the episode inside his big armory if you
don't remember that character it's a super deep
cut white dragon is this big white supremacist
kkk villain from the dc comics so they're just
adding to the list of things that peacemaker has
to come to terms with by the end of the season
to complete his arc there's another teaser for a
future episode when he enters the house there's
this newscast about charlie who's named like
my name local silverback gorilla at the zoo
in the town where they are where this is taking
place that they'll probably pay off later like how
could a giant silverback gorilla possibly escape
think of it like chekhov's silverback gorilla like
at some point you just have to imagine john cena
peacemaker getting into a big brawl with an actual
full-on silverback gorilla because we're talking
about the decent universe anytime you talk about
gorillas you have to think about gorilla grodd
and the intelligent gorillas they've been doing
a version of that character on the flash tv
show for a long long time peacemaker then uses
his father's secret lair to grab the x-ray vision
helmet as many other helmets as he can fit in his
bag too i love the way he doubles back like you
know what i better just grab all these helmets
vigilante walks in love how he seems so
nonchalant about all the weapons like oh you know
this seems totally normal what's going on here
peacemaker then finally explains it's basically
just a quantum unfolding storage facility that's
basically a pocket dimension outside the main dceu
universe so far the only way they've explained
his father having this technology is that he's
supposed to be very smart like a very smart racist
but they might also tie it to some of the other
stuff that's going on with the aliens during the
series like this really cool hypertech this seems
so far beyond that anything we've seen in any
of the other dc movies even like the full-blown
justice league movie like how can peacemaker's
father have all this but batman doesn't have
stuff that is cool and speaking of batman as he
walks out his neighbor catches him and continues
arguing with him about why he's not a superhero
like batman like batman has a rogue's gallery of
villains do you have a rogue's gallery of villains
he names joker riddler mad hatter meaning that
there is a version of dceu riddler in mad hatter
out there the version that we're going to see the
riddler in the batman movie with robert pattinson
is an earth 2 version so not inside the dc eu so
whoever dceu riddler winds up being he'd be played
by some different actor theoretically i also think
this conversation in a lot of the other scenes
in the episode where peacemakers sort of trying
to come to grips with what's really going on with
his father like the truth about his father is also
foreshadowing his father becoming his own personal
super villain that he has to take down and after
he does he will realize that officially qualifies
him as a superhero like batman like i have a super
villain that must mean that i am a superhero then
when they argue about whether or not batman kills
people that's actually incorrect because dceu
batman ben affleck's batman did kill people during
batman v superman and this is the dceu ergo batman
kills people and if you go back and you watch the
michael keaton batman movies i believe the kill
count in his movies is way higher than the kill
count in all the ben affleck batman appearances
but it's a little bit of meta commentary about all
the batman killing people batman using guns that
has been happening for the past six or seven years
while ben affleck has been batman it's just kind
of meant to be a joke about all the people online
arguing about stuff like that he also tries to
make the moral argument that batman is a murderer
on the technicality that he's responsible for all
the people who were murdered by his villains after
they escaped from arkham asylum because he didn't
kill them when he had the chance really he's just
trying to make himself feel better for all the
people that he's killed like killing rick flagg
which he continues to grapple with during the
episode during several of his scenes where he
starts to freak out a little bit and gets super
high they flash back both to his childhood when
his father forced him to kill people and they
intercut that with him flashing back to killing
rick flag as if killing someone as a child kind of
broke him and it also broke him again to kill rick
flagg there are a couple moments of self-awareness
from him in the episode too where he's like okay
i get it yes my father is super racist it's just
that he's been so traumatized his whole life that
he's kind of pushed reality away which is why he
seems so out of touch with reality in present day
the whole thing with the missing money that emilia
harcourt and john economos are whispering about
in the background of this scene sounds like the
money trail tied to the butterflies and senator
goff in the gland tie bottling company that all
the butterflies are using to create that weird
honey fluid that is their food source if it wasn't
clear that honey fluid is basically the only thing
that they consume and they're making it at this
glan tai place that they keep referencing in the
last couple of episodes i believe we're actually
going to visit that place in episode 5 next week
we've seen a couple scenes of that in
the trailers like the scene with the
jokes about peacemaker's homemade bomb what
the hell is that it's a grenade i tied to a
russian tank shell how many people does this
blow up i don't know i meant it at the sport
then i'm not totally sure but i believe
this rabbit with a cape on it with the ub
on his chest is either meant to be a reference to
ubics the green lantern rabbit creature villain
or could be a reference to ultra boy from the
legion of superheroes there aren't that many
dc characters that look like rabbits with the
initials you be when vigilante and peacemaker
are apologizing to each other they continue
to foreshadow peacemaker fighting his father
vigilante's suggesting that he's going to have to
take his father down like you would take a super
villain down like i said i think the writing's
on the wall but there is a funny reference later
that they make which i think kind of foreshadows
the way that they'll deal with his father by the
finale is when leota's apologizing for trying to
get vigilante to kill peacemaker's father in so
many words john economos corrects mirn saying that
eagerly is peacemaker's best friend in the make
this comment about his best friend killing his
father and eagerly killing peacemaker's father
several characters actually repeat that idea so
i think what they're trying to foreshadow here
is that eagley might actually wind up being the
character to kill peacemaker's father because
that seems like a pretty hilarious takedown like
can you imagine them putting robert patrick inside
that costume like old man robert patrick and
present day back inside the white dragon costume
but having him killed by eagley just something in
the tone of the humor they've been going for with
the peacemaker series the really dark jokes the
other funny thing about leota here too is that
when murn asks her to keep an eye on peacemaker
because she's the only one he trusts the only
member that he was sure was not a butterfly that
actually foreshadows the big turn at the end of
the episode where they reveal that mirn has been
taken over by the butterflies so it turns out
peacemaker's intuition is actually pretty accurate
love the way the judo master also escapes from his
bonds only to steal more potato chips while
he's hiding inside that little closet there
you just have to imagine him in that tiny little
closet eating potato chips in the dark waiting
for john economos to come back it's also a funny
way to bring back that flamin hot cheetos joke
then this whole conversation that leota has with
peacemaker about wanting to believe your parents
are innately good inside but flawed people is also
part of her arc coming to terms with her mother
amanda waller being just as bad as all the super
villains that they're trying to stop also probably
just as bad as peacemaker's father the only
difference between amanda waller and peacemaker's
father is that peacemaker's father is so over the
top comedically racist and bad that he seems worse
but amanda waller is bad in a more insidious kind
of way because she says that everything that she
does is necessary in the name of peace justice in
protecting the us government and remember the us
government is actually one of the biggest villains
of the suicide squad movie that we just saw with
starro they referenced peacemaker's brother a
couple times his father basically says you know
i wish that he would have survived instead of you
later at the end of the episode there are a bunch
of flashbacks that they intercut a peacemaker as
a child and then peacemaker with his brother and
his brother's death that imply what happened first
they flash back to his father forcing him to kill
someone to toughen him up and look at the mullet
on robert patrick here that is the most epic
mullet you will ever see then he flashes back to
his brother listening to 80s hair metal with him
and in a separate flashback after that his
brother dies in what seems like a fight but
they only show you part of the fight i think what
they're implying here is that his father forced
the two of them to fight each other to the death
like forced peacemaker to either kill his brother
or be killed himself and that's what ultimately
broke him and caused him to kind of freeze in his
state of mental development like he just kind of
mentally checked out as a way of dealing with the
trauma of what he'd done and that's why he seemed
so out of touch with reality in present day in why
his file says that he was implicated in the death
of his brother then the way that leota explained
this later when she's talking to vigilante
about wishing peacemaker's father would die
somehow so that he could be happy vigilante taking
it is inspiration to help his friend by killing
the father leota revealed she basically went full
amanda waller playing four-dimensional chess mind
games with him being a master manipulator just
like her mother does with suicide squad characters
but as you see from the prison riot his father
is no fool like he understands what's going on
like i'm not gonna fight you because it'll look
like i'm responsible for all this when vigilante
says i think i made it worse what he means is that
peacemaker's father now thinks that the team the
suicide squad team is trying to kill him so he'll
retaliate in kind and i think that's just all in
service of setting him up as more of an actual
villain for the team and for peacemaker himself
by the finale like i actually do think that
james gunn is going to put robert patrick back
inside that white dragon costume back at their
video store base when peacemaker goes after judo
master he does a pretty solid superhero landing
the atomic age sign on the truck kind of makes me
think it's an atom reference and because john cena
is mostly known as a wrestling star they play this
fight like a traditional wrestling match even
though judo master is like this four foot tall
martial artist like he picks him up like a rag
doll and just throws him around all over the place
leota winds up killing him paying off the scenes
of her agonizing over not being able to pull the
trigger like i think part of the idea is that
peacemaker will slowly become a better person
over the course of the series and she'll become
more of a hardcore person like they're both on
opposite sides of the spectrum right now and
they're both coming towards center when juno
master was trying to reveal more information
about the butterflies though before the fight
they thought the butterflies were these alien
invaders taking over human bodies like parasites
trying to take over the planet so if judo master
is saying that that's not correct like you have
the wrong idea something else is going on early
theory it might be another twist on the suicide
squad story tropes about how the mission isn't
always the real mission like the suicide squad
teams were sent to courtois mauties under false
pretense the real mission was to prevent the rest
of the world from learning the truth about the
us government being responsible for starro in
the first place so there's meant to be a big fake
out twist with the butterflies maybe they aren't
really evil and they're trying to either get home
to where they came from or stop some larger threat
or it's truly like the suicide squad movie twist
and the butterflies are also somehow victims of
something the us government did to them in the
past and i think the big twist with peacemaker
saving the butterfly actually supports this theory
because the whole idea is that he's having trouble
killing innocent people and if he didn't kill the
butterfly i think that's them foreshadowing that
it will also wind up not being quite as evil
as you believe and as for judo master they do
imply that he'll survive like they bandage him up
and put him on an iv and i'll be able to finish
explaining the truth about the butterflies love
the deep cut apple dumpling gang movie reference
that mirn makes too i have not watched that movie
in a billion years but if you have not seen it
they kind of recap the plot very briefly during
the episode they give you an idea for the context
it's meant to be a metaphor for this suicide
squad team the apple dumpling gang is a team of
incompetent people a game of criminals who
ultimately stumble their way into a victory
like cramer themselves into victory the way that
these characters will probably do by the finale
also the apple dumpling gang movie star's
bill bixby is one of the main characters
aka the incredible hulk so another nice comic book
connection there too mr mcgee don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry also when
leota is apologizing for the whole deal with
peacemaker's father and vigilante there's a movie
poster above murn that says daddy meant to be a
metaphor for peacemaker's daddy issues then at
the end of the episode love the way peacemaker
kind of breaks down getting high and then getting
the butterfly high i'm pretty sure it appreciates
the freebie we have seen that the butterflies do
appreciate human culture then i already explained
all the flashbacks the peacemaker has and what
they're saying about his brother him being forced
to kill his brother by his father i think we'll
get the rest of this flashback in a future episode
leota makes the connection to the glan tai
bottling company that the butterflies are using to
make that honey fluid that is their food source i
think we're going there in next week's episode and
they reveal that mirn has been a butterfly this
whole time i think what they're trying to say here
is that while we've been watching him on the show
since the events of episode one the whole time
he's been a butterfly but we don't know his full
backstory yet they've kind of only teased that so
we'll probably get that reveal in a future episode
and we'll find out when he became a butterfly but
if it wasn't clear the movie he's watching on the
tv here is a lethal weapon then because they do
post credit scenes in all the episodes the episode
4 post credit scene is a longer version of that
duck argument that they had inside his father's
pocket dimension i felt like for a minute they
might be going for howard the duck reference
because james gunn did the guardians of the
galaxy movies featuring versions of howard the
duck in both of those we'll probably see howard
the duck come back during guardians of the galaxy
3 too but if you spotted any other big easter eggs
in the episode that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments and
post all your theories about how they're going to
end this series and what's really going on with
the butterflies my full peacemaker episode 5 video
we'll post next week just like normal and there's
a whole bunch of stuff that's happening this week
and next week so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss it everyone click
here for my full marvel moon night trailer video
and click here for my full star wars book
of boba fett episode 4 video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!